warum software eine statt zwei stunden
show angucken wenn es auch in einer
stunde geld
geht so schnell es ist alles oder nichts
es kann nicht ein bisschen schief
geändert das ist ja ganz schön lang wir
haben geld das ganz schief
ich war in südamerika und ich glaube die
leute aber das ist natürlich hat auch zu
tun mit die kultur die die die hatten
angst vor mich die die vergleichen das
mit foto und schwarzer magie
ich hatte gleich gedacht war ich habe
sich auf jedem markt angeschaut und das
alles war so langweilig ich hatte
gedacht dass ich schneller sein meine
frau und ich wir haben drei jahre
arbeiten an drei illusionen und habe
meinen vater gedacht okay damit kann er
ein herbststurm machen und da war die
kasse für warme winde wie fünf minuten
ich habe einmal mit einer elefanten
verschwinden lassen mit r liefern hat er
keine lust hat gesagt ich glaube hier
stehen ich hatte diese eltern bedeckt
mit einem riesen trug und dann die
weggenommen und da waren auch in die elf
es ist der bestbezahlte martin
assistentin den history
gedanken ist ein bisschen hobby von
pamela anderson und sie ziemlich gute
ein wirklich zum beispiel beim pendler
eine eine männer auf die straße sieht
dann weiß ich gleich verdienen man denkt
sie habe mit vielen schönen frauen
zusammengearbeitet
wird es wäre weil so ein amt zu bleiben
der eigentliche gutefrage.net am
kreml hat auch um wieviel hoffe glaube
ich
augenzwinkern augen zwingt das alles ist
mit einem augenzwinkern